when I first saw this film was an IMAX  theater and I literally could not  breathe it felt like I was in space here  we go twelve habitable worlds right  within our reach and save us from  extinction I've never been so engulfed  in a story that's a great thing to  experience Cooper it's too damn fast I  got this very graceful you're not gonna  get the beauty of film you're not gonna  get that scope and size and epic scale  that Christopher Nolan puts on the  screen like nobody else unless you go  see it in IMAX then I say the movies an  experience we have a mission that we  plan does not work if the people on  earth are dead by the time we pull it  off there's no other movie that I can  think of that more necessitates go into  the theaters to see it in this  it's not just going to the movies you're  going into space  you